hello and welcome to this video plains
UK to keep something like that name from
Iceland
again this early I she in Cairo here
there are a couple of interesting lines
this is one of them seem probable cause
on some e60 yeah it isn't all that
gradient from me I mean it's getting
some pressure on that pawn one thing
that black has to be a bit cautious with
the some though either playing the pawn
to d6 as this we can see six quite a bit
ok and looks like he wants to take it
yeah be should be three looks who did
story but okay I have 95 as an idea so
it's not like Quincy ages and is like
fantastic in all kinds of regards so we
are night I don't know that before
doesn't do much all that much let's
let's develop first
86 okay
so let's let's keep everything and
threaten before him
and the light has no squares whatsoever
some tests here there has to be some
some concession now I think yeah now
before this 96 so after we capture first
maybe a five is the right move so we
wants to play some tactics here we can
show me night age 5 or what is your
point kind of curious what is the blacks
point here
right h 552 I mean that night has no
squares so efficiently to yes
Jim how does he save it I don't really
see how ya a 94 this this I saw but I
couldn't really believe it so just
moving this bishop and then queen d 4 is
looking great um okay if I take it
let's retreat this and have Queen deform
on the cards and maybe 28 I mean and 3d
for Queen f6 somehow hordes maybe
maybe I should have gone to a one and
two have it protected huh okay
still hard to believe that blank should
survive it
here Knight f6 I just take it I only for
i'm in me so quindi for like f6 so long
and let's play it first so g4s might be
five but it doesn't help them not much
I just said I go Queen h6 threatening
925 5595 SS music total kill and now
maybe you get queen of eight or
something but don't care don't care now
too many bees as in the attack yeah can
you take the night check it's a pretty
nice check Knight f6 check black
resigned yeah no no event did this
correctly somehow it took two extremely
dangerous for him yeah absolutely
thought yes you're away five now and I
don't think it was all that bad I mean
this the computer saying gives me a
slight edge yeah rookie one or so it's
just a family having normal it's the
wrong word but it's it doesn't feel like
I'm winning immediately or something and
here this seems she'll be dangerous so
this is correct yeah now I didn't know
taking going back I went back okay
Quincy for it's not something I looked
at this 95 was good but I don't think
this is bad you know check I did I did
okay in between age 6 yeah Queen f8 is
the better defense definitely he didn't
really see that 95 is that deadly okay I
didn't really have a clear plan but
Bishop this looks good yeah I'm
threatening him yeah it's very nice for
wine but not yet as devastating as the
game was here things completely shank
can clearly fall apart ok guys thanks
for watching
you